do you consider yourself an artist
oh wow um do i consider myself an artist
i would say yes in the sense that uh i
try to do something
creative every day and i try to live
what i would describe
as a creative life i drove to your place
here
in my car and most people that buy a car
they just okay they get their car and
that's it i i
have no allegiance to toyota and i
turned my car
into a batmobile where i have batman
stickers in certain places on the
hubcaps on all the interior in the
console
i covered up the toyota logo with a
batman logo
um and so i try to like and if you ever
come to my place everything from the
bookshelves is just something
creatively stimulating everywhere i
always have some creative project i'm
doing whether i'm modifying
something and then even with my
website and film projects there's sort
of a handmade feel to it so i guess
artists would be an all-encompassing
thing
um in that describes the way i live my
life also the way
uh i like to write i don't i just like
to like
if everyone's doing this thing i'm
trying to do
i'm trying to go the other way or find
another way or we've heard this line a
million times
i'm going to try something different so
um i i would say that
like artists would be a good
all-encompassing thing but i would never
say that about myself um
but i but i think in and live that way
because
i i tend to not accept the choices we're
given
and by that i mean
one of the things when i was in high
school uh
they try to see what your capacity is
for certain careers right and
one of the questions that puzzled um a
teacher of mine was why did you put that
hours of work don't mean it matter to
you don't you want to work a nine to
five
job and i said no
um i don't the hours don't matter
and so i look at the choices we're
presented in terms of
how it's possible to live your life and
i
try to do something different and maybe
that's
uh sort of a bit of a gen x rebel in me
but also
um something of i just can't do
i can't accept a thing as like this is
the only option right which is why i
altered my card to not look like
anybody's car
and i will say this um whenever i do
have
the luxury of valet parking my car the
valet parkers love it
and i always just say get my batmobile
um so so there you go would you consider
yourself a businessman
i i definitely would consider myself a
business person from this
standpoint the most successful artists
that you know about that you have
awareness of
whether it be steven spielberg as a
filmmaker
or other filmmakers steven soderbergh
and this is the challenge of working in
film
is that you have to be wildly creative
on the one hand and that describes a lot
of people
but the ones that succeed the one the
ones that work
consistently have an output of work are
the ones that are
very good at business and so that is i
think the biggest challenge facing
filmmakers is to balance the artist side
which a lot of times
conflicts with being a business person
because what i learned about being
about being successful in business is
it's all about
deconstructing and doing doing kind of a
little autopsy
on your process and then coming up with
the successful parts of the process and
then repeating it
for example having written a couple of
books non-fiction in the nonfiction
realm i would always have friends
ask well how did you write a book and i
said i didn't write a book i wrote a
thousand words a day
and i did that every day and i did it
five days a week
because i got up at five a.m and i
worked till 8 am when i was spent
i had about a thousand words on a good
day 3000 words
on a bad day maybe 500 words but i did
that
every day 5 days a week never not
for months and within 60
70 days i had enough words for a book
the average book
is 60 to 70 000 words so
what you don't know is before that i
spent six months on an outline for that
book
so what i began to learn um and just
through many
sort of business wonky books that i have
read i tend to sort of glean
there's always like a read a book like
the four hour work week or
the seven habits of highly successful
people and
i usually get like one or two nuggets of
like oh that's really good but you gotta
like sift through that 60
000 words to get to that like that you
know a
pot of gold of knowledge
but i began to realize that part of this
is about
is about breaking down processes no one
writes a book or just makes a movie or
writes a screenplay
it's breaking that process down into the
smallest smallest task
and then just doing that task every day
like anything
and creating a habit and i think that
scientifically speaking um they say that
it takes about three weeks
to instill a habit and i think that if
you can
develop those good habits and just do a
piece
even if it's a paragraph you're gonna
have
i mean it boggles my mind when i see
people who do these long
facebook posts or social media social
media posts and i look at that and i
said if you took that energy
and you put it into like a book or a
screenplay
or some other piece of work
and you just you would really have
something i feel like i feel like we're
we're giving away our creativity to
these social media companies
and it i i it's it's
it's really disheartening to see a
generation waste their time
with these long-winded posts when you
could actually have have created
a work of some cohesive work um
but back to the book thing i i i do like
tend to spend about
six months coming up with an outline a
very detailed outline
usually about between 15 and 30 pages
and then that outline i i detail usually
it's like here's the chapter heading
here are the sub heads
and here's a sentence about that will
describe
the next 500 words i'm going to write
i've literally written the book in my
head
so then it's a matter of just going back
and then doing that daily routine of
getting up very early in the morning
kind of when you're in that lucid state
this is pre-coffee
pre-caffeine so you're so you're not
quite all there
and you're in almost a trance-like state
and a lot of writers will talk about
that you're just sort of your um what
they call
in the zone you get it's it's easier to
get in the zone when you're
you know fresh out of bed pre-caffeine
and that was always that was a process
that worked for me
other people it works differently i feel
like you have to kind of know yourself
to know what works for you other people
late night that's their most
productivity for me it's mornings
so i think getting to know how you
function as a creative machine is
extremely helpful
and then coming up with a series of
repeatable processes
um where you're successful and then
feedback also to any artist is like air
i mean you need it to live you need
feedback
both positive and critical to
to grow i'm always very skeptical when
someone
compliments me i don't take a compliment
very well so um
but i will take a note a really specific
note
seriously so that it can be so it's an
addressable note whether it's
um uh i don't know a
film project or whether it's a book
project
um notes notes are i feel like i give
good notes too
i think i think you you you have to
learn to give good notes as well as like
take those notes
um in as part of that process did you
know
living a creative life meant not living
a nine to five
life 100
i was well aware that living a creative
life would not mean nine to five i mean
i i can just i can even tell you
when i'm out like socially and having
fun i'm still working
there's a part of my brain that is
always kind of um
i'm never not without a a notepad
and i tend to like like to physically
write like a notepad and i've always
carried in my pocket
um god for um probably
almost 30 years i always carry a space
pen
um this is the uh this is the
space pen that was developed by nasa
uh they spent 10 million dollars to
create a technology
which um seals the ink so that it forces
it out right
and the russians used a pencil but we
americans
invented this pen they're about 25 bucks
uh
the ink lasts maybe four to five years
i've always got a backup when this one
runs out
it's never not with me so
napkins if i don't have a notepad or a
tiny notepad i love those little
tiny notepads um and i will
if it's an emergency write notes in my
phone
i may not like to do that um but i
prefer the heart
um but yeah i i'm kind of always working
or always like or something will spark
something and i do think that
that's where that early morning work
like once i'm sort of spent
my brain is still working on a problem
how to solve a creative problem
still working still working still
working i just don't have the solution
and sometimes taking a step away is the
best
best way to for your brain to continue
that work subconsciously
and i found that that that works for me
as part of the pre
creative process also i love to be
stimulated by um
like i don't know um dive bars
are fun um that may not work for
everybody uh the horse races
are fun um i like to just go somewhere
where there's
a lot of life being lived and and
observe and and um i i find that
uh that is also very stimulating to the
to the creative process
would you consider yourself a contrarian
yeah i'm i'm 100 a contrarian i mean i
can just tell
um when i look at old photos of myself i
was almost
never on point with whatever the fashion
of the day was if this was the fashion
of the day
i was over here you know what i mean
like i can't and even when it
comes to thinking about things you know
like
the films even that film threat had
championed at the time weren't the ones
that ever became
big hits i mean we covered people like
quentin tarantino earlier in their
career or richard linklater
in the 90s when film threat was a print
magazine and just to explain to some
some of the people out there that may
not know what a print magazine is
print magazine is just like the internet
but it's but it's uh
printed on really thin slices of wood
and magazines were sold at things called
bookstores
and you go to a bookstore you get a
magazine
i'm gonna we're joking i'm joking of
course you guys know what magazines are
books come on um but yeah no i i mean i
was a magazine i was
effectively a media junkie and i at one
point
was subscribing to 50 magazines that i
would get every month
and they all across the gamut artist
magazines stuff about comic books pop
culture science fiction
the business of publishing folio being
one
newsweek i mean i was a media junkie now
it's easy to be a media junkie with you
know access to
everything online um but back in the 80s
and 90s
that was that was not as easy a thing
um but yeah i'm definitely a contrarian
in the sense that i
look at like and this has always been a
problem for me whenever i have worked
for a traditional
company because i do like to look at
processes like and like this is how
film threat if you look at my website
and our
you know what we do on our youtube
channel and whatnot some might think oh
this is a
big organization of a lot of people and
it is represents about 30 writers
located all over the world
um but we just have a process for how we
do things
that leads to being able to put out
and cover so many films that
don't get coverage in your traditional
mainstream media and that's just from
looking at processes when i work for
traditional companies what usually tends
to happen is i look at how they're doing
something i think oh
i know how i would do that better and
that would save me hours
i'll give you an example i wrote a book
years ago called the ultimate film
festival survival guide
and in the process of writing that book
i created a database
of film festivals and i would time
myself how long it took to
compile this data and i used a very
simple at the time
spreadsheet program and i would type in
the data and it it took a while it took
like
15 20 minutes for each festival well i
was trying to collect data on 2
000 film festivals located all over the
world
so i talked to an intern of mine at the
time and i and i
and i said to him and said hey what do
you think if i gave away a
ps3 and maybe bought some pizza and
drinks for some college students
so we got about 60 college students
together i bought them
pizza and drinks i got them all in front
of their computers
logged into a database and i calculated
in my head with the number of students
how long it takes it's going to take us
three to four hours blah blah blah
like and i will have all the data so
they had a name of a film festival they
went they found the website and then
they just put in all the data points
and at the end we did a drawing and
somebody won a ps3
and i had all the data for my book and
it happened in just an
evening so again that was just sort of a
a way of looking at what is what is the
end goal how can i get there
and then what is what is a way to do it
where everybody gets something out of it
and i kind of feel like in a lot of ways
in my career i've
tom sawyerd myself into you know the
tom sawyer story where he's painting the
white picket fence
and he enlists the aid of everyone to
help him paint the fence so he's
you know um i'm not saying i'm also not
there painting the fence
but that is how i've been able to do
a lot of what i'm doing is taking a look
at like this is how you would do this in
the real world is you would hire a
company
to collect that data for you and they
would charge you between twenty and
thirty thousand dollars
or i could buy a ps3 some pizza and
drinks we can have a good
fun night and and and
i get i collect that data so i always
look at like how can i be competitive
and how can i do something
and i think a lot of it is um there's
with my organization there's just very
few layers of approval i mean it's
a very small group of people so there's
not
a lot of hand-wringing
over decision making you know it's like
cut to the chase what's our end goal
let's let's come up with that process
and boom so we can
get something done we can be very
efficient whether it's
an award show we're doing or some some
documentary project
um and this is gonna sound weird but i
will like um even for
we did this award show called award this
um which is my part of our mission
sort of completes our mission with film
threat where we're championing
smaller indie movies that get no love in
award season
zero um these are movies that are small
that don't get love from say the even
the independent spirit awards and i
wanted to create an event
that um really was diverse in the sense
that
you know we were awarding every
giving acknowledgement to films uh on
the spectrum everything from like coded
bias
um by shalini kentaya whose movie played
sundance
and then a movie called corona zombies
directed by charlie band from full moon
entertainment which is a schlock
exploitation zombie movie so
we did that and we um we even had gift
bags for the event and i just timed how
long it takes to
stuff a gift bag and then i knew that if
we had this many people we'd do it in
this amount of time this sounds kind of
like
in a way like um
because now i can hear myself saying
this i sound like a crazy person but
you're a virgo though right yes so how
did you guess that oh it says it on your
imdb
oh it just says you're september 5th or
whatever oh i'm a
yes and if you see um
yes i i have all all the aspects of
virgo that you would say like you know
neatnik perfectionist all that like yes
that's me yes
but but i try to come up with i don't
try to not like burden anyone else
anyone else with my uh with those
aspects of my personality
so i try to make it a a a gift um
at least within our organization right
like this is
this is the thing that i'm good at i'm
not good at what
other members of my team are good at and
collectively
um you know we're able to do what we do
but yes yeah i i uh yeah i fit into all
all of those aspects um and uh
and try to approach everything with some
sort of precision
but i've learned that timing out tasks
just tells you how long something is
going to take
i mean i would i would even say to
anyone pursuing writing
the thing that i always look at is how
long did it take and i do a word count
you know no matter what program i'm
using
i just do a word count or a page count
and
what did i produce how much time is it
repeatable
and where do i have to get how do i have
to get in the zone what are the
circumstances
what is the time of day i don't like
to work when leith the leaf blowers are
around distractions
i'm very prone to distraction so
um yeah so so uh
i find that it's useful to break things
down
into a process and to know yourself
you